I've told people that are Native
American they're like what is that what
does that mean I mean I'm like I'm an
indigenous I'm from here like I'm here
[Music]
the movie came out when I was a child
and it was the first like native
anything that I seen right I see the
good in it you know I could see natives
on the screen but then you have songs
like savages savages you know barely
even human there's like [ __ ] like
that that's in there I liked it when I
was a child but as an adult I don't know
yeah I mean like some of those songs are
bangers right like colors are the wind
like you listen to that all day I mean
maybe not that one that one's definitely
offensive I would jump over there for
that it's tough because like it gave us
a place to like have something to speak
against or to say anything about so like
do I need to be mad about it that it
actually gave us like some sort of on
screen even though it's a cartoon I
don't know I think it's great that we
can talk about it now but the fact that
it exists I think it's a dangerous
depiction especially of Native women and
a lot of our youth have had to
experience difficult things racist
things because of the imagery it further
engraves those stereotypes that somehow
Native women all dressed like that sexy
like way back then and like my opinion
of Pocahontas has evolved over time I
would say 6 year old me would say
strongly disagree because I saw a native
woman and it was a happy romanticized
you know story of Pocahontas but as I've
grown up I've done more research on her
story and what's happened to her
mine definitely does not
there's no good advertising because they
don't have the funding or enough funding
to like advertise it and market it
really well so every time I'm there to
get my favorite chicken fingers and
mashed potatoes their own customer bases
their own people and so they're not
really bringing in revenue from tourism
or anything like that or just people
driving down I need yeah I mean like the
the Chickasaw Nation like we're able to
provide all sorts of services for our
community because of profits from our
casinos like just basic health care like
we have that like school services all
these things and it's very beneficial to
my community my tribe is new to gaming
but I as far as I know Navajo Nation
scholarships could increase because of
all of the gaming and that revenue but I
haven't seen it like the Navajo Nation
scholarships are not very much at all I
think that that's a huge stereotype that
a lot of people are always like oh well
you guys have casinos okay yeah my tribe
has more than one casino but you don't
see me rolling in money and getting
monthly cash payments like that's it's
just it's just a stereotype there's also
these you know there's negative aspects
of it like you know if people come in on
the rez and thinking that it's you know
their place to party and you know do
whatever they want one of my friends on
Facebook posted something about our our
casinos and how they're kind of
contributing to the so the missing
murdered indigenous women crisis how
that's a lot of women come up missing at
these locations and they're hotspots for
human trafficking just to put it in
perspective for people that don't know
what this issue is in 2016
five thousand seven hundred and twelve
women were reported missing and that's
only 2016 you know they deemed this
epidemic a genocide and that there are
just thousands and thousands of women
going missing and murdered
and so this is something that you know
we need to find solutions for because
they don't even know our history don't
understand our trauma and you know I
my younger brother committed suicide
when he was 17 my little brother was one
of eight Navajo boys that committed
suicide that summer in my area and you
know when I when I talk about that
they're like oh my god like what can we
do they don't even know that we exist at
times
we're so invisible you know so like we
have to first show people that were
still [ __ ] here and then we have to
educate them on all the [ __ ] trauma
that we've been through all the you know
and that's the that's the whole reason
that we have like the highest statistics
for like suicide for new cases of HIV
and AIDS for you know I'd be all these
different you know things because of all
these traumas that we've had to go
through as people I don't know if
anybody else has gotten this when you're
asked like what what are you what are
you I was like I'm Native American I'm
waiting for all those questions to
happen oh do you do dream catchers do
you wear moccasins all these fun things
but the one that really pisses me off is
so you all have drinking problems right
it's like oh dude like I mean it kills
because you don't know why we have
drinking problems or some have
unfortunately have that to carry well
the government made treaties with
indigenous people on every single one of
them has been broken you know that's why
for a long time a lot of our communities
have been like suffering because of what
the government has put us through and
relocated us to different parts of
Turtle Island away from our original
homelands where we were personal
experience like when I tell someone I'm
Chickasaw and then
nope I'm from Oklahoma they're like well
how did you how'd your family get to
Oklahoma it's like Trail of Tears dog
that's like like I understand why we
don't talk about it but it's not good
that we don't we got to find like a
place to speak about it but in a way
that doesn't like doesn't create like
guilt for like just an individual
because like that person has not done
anything to me I'm not trying to make
them feel guilty oh I just think that
you need to understand that there was
this trauma and there are reasons why
our communities are fractured because of
this
[Music]
you know during the 70's the whole
during the american indian movement
there was fighting between full bloods
half you know and that created this
divide of you know who's more of the
superior native who's more of the full
blood you know if you can prove that you
are native whether you're 1/16 but you
can prove it I'm totally for that I feel
like blood quantum creates a divide and
it's further you know separating us from
our culture and from who we are another
thing we have to look at too is for
folks who are multiple tribes you know
we live in an urban environment I know
people who are like five or six tribes
they're not eligible for enrollment in
any one their full blood native they're
from all these different tribes but they
can't enroll in one because they're not
enough of that one particular tribe
there they still have all these
connections to the community they have
all these ties they do all these but
they're not enrolled they're you know
they're not they don't have that
connection on paper you know we can't
help that we're mixed blood because of
our histories and what happened what
happened to us you know our ancestors
were raped they were taken from their
tribes so we have a lot of people a lot
of Native people coming back today who
want to be part of the community and we
should be accepting of that and we ich
blood-quantum shouldn't matter you know
that's who they are well for myself I'm
full-blooded tonal awesome but I know
that there are a lot of there are people
that can say that they are native and
they're not and that can be very hurtful
to people that need to get the same
benefits in college I was looking I got
a list of all the people that were
Native in my college and I went and I
found everybody and this one girl was
like oh yeah I just said that so I could
get in because the school didn't ask for
any you know they're just like oh if
you're Native check this box so for me I
I say that yeah that I somewhat agree
that it does matter I mean I see the
benefits too because sometimes when you
have to apply to something like
scholarships or certain things you know
they do want accurate records yeah but
like how much is enough blood because
like I think if we're going to say that
blood Quantum's are important
then how much is enough to be a native
person it's hard like when when people
are want you to prove that you're Native
all the time I am very mixed with like
so many different races but like the one
I grew up knowing about and the one that
I identified with was Chickasaw because
that was the dominant one in my
household and that was like what we what
we did but in a lot of communities like
people who are more Native than I am or
indigenous than I am we'll be like well
you kind of can't speak to this because
you don't know what it feels like and
it's like yeah I do because I grew up
with that exact same thing as you but I
just don't look exactly like you the
trauma is still there how do you justify
that I am less because of like my blood
is less I was adopted and so I feel I'm
somewhat agree because growing up I
didn't know my identity I grew up in a
predominantly Caucasian neighborhood and
I stood out because I'm dark skinned
dark hair and people be like what are
you there was a disconnect but as an
adult I don't feel that way at all like
every day I'm very proud I'm very
excited and I'm happy to tell people
that I'm talking about them I mean I
didn't feel ashamed until I was nine
growing up on the reservation in Lower
Burrell South Dakota and surrounded by
my family and culture and we were just
so close and that's what you know our
tribal communities bring to us but then
my dad got a job out in Maine the most
rural place you could go and that's
where I started experiencing racism and
started seeing that I was different and
being called a prairie [ __ ] having
brass knuckles shoved in my face because
a hate crime was happening because I was
walking with a white student who was
walking me to my dad's office for a long
time I really hated who I was I was
embarrassed to be brown now I [ __ ]
own it my experience is a little bit
different I grew up in North Jersey New
York Canada all around and I still never
ever felt like racially profiled it
wasn't until maybe high school when I
moved back home a lot of the the
Iroquois kids the Mohawk kids you know
they lived there their whole life I had
moved around so much I think that's the
only time I felt a little ashamed is
because I didn't have any roots but
other than that I still felt welcomed I
felt part of this group part of that
group for me getting more in touch with
my culture learning about where I come
from that's what really saved my life so
I feel like I've never been ashamed that
it just makes me more proud being a
queer indigenous person as well that's
you know brought me out of a really dark
place learning about what my role is in
the community as a two-spirit person I
was a meth addict for a very long time
as a child from the time I was 14 years
old to the time I was 19
looking back to my upbringing and my
culture and all that the things that
gave me a sense of identity that's what
brought me out of those dark places yes
they do
oh our people tons of things can't even
imagine like the list I've got in my
head but I think too we owe ourselves
some stuff - reclamation decolonization
we need to love ourselves more yeah I
agree that's why I'm gonna say strongly
agree because yeah we're stepping up and
we're more educated and stronger than
ever but you know I do think that we
deserve better healthcare we deserve
better educational systems we deserve
better textbooks in our schools I'm not
expecting anything as far as like being
owed but what I would like it doesn't
cost any money is an apology as an
acknowledgement they've done that in
other countries where they're like oh
we're sorry we came in and we
massacred your indigenous population and
they apologize for it and that much I
think that we rode and I think that that
would help bring a lot of healing
amongst our people just be I mean I can
only speak for like myself as an
I can't speak for everybody or even a
collective because I'm only one person
but like an apology doesn't like heal me
any more I mean like it's cool I would
that would be good but like it doesn't
make me like do anything different than
I'm doing now I just I don't think that
feeling
owed gives us the same place of power
that knowing that like nonono has been
anything I'm just gonna get it me just
keeping it real
maybe that comes from a little bit of
this you know cause the rhythm is a real
thing it happens and maybe you don't
feel that because of you know you have a
different place in this society than
somebody else with the darker skin tone
well I mean I'll address that in high
school I stopped going outside because I
would get too dark and I had long hair
and so I have felt that so I know what
you're saying but like even during that
time even when I would like go to
Walmart and get followed around even
when I would get pulled over four times
a week for driving while Brown I still
was in the same mindset of like I am
going to get it regardless of what's in
front of me so I mean maybe that's just
me a personality thing but I like as far
as like skin colour goes like I felt it
I think though or I'm looking at it from
the perspective like they don't owe me
[ __ ] but if they can acknowledge and
hold themselves accountable and what
they have done and what previous
presidents have done previous
governments that creates a new path for
change because when you admit to
something and acknowledge that it's
there then that behavior changes I think
we need investment and accountability
and I'm not even coming at it from like
a monetary standpoint like Oh give us
millions of dollars and we'll call it
even and we need people to care and you
know we need accountability
[Applause]
hi everyone thanks for sticking around
for the end Aaron I know that this is an
episode that was really near and dear to
your heart can you just tell us why you
wanted to is absent so I'm not Native
American but I am Native Hawaiian and an
indigenous person and I do feel like
they indigenous people are not in the
media at all or they're shown in a very
inaccurate way and so I thought this is
an opportunity to shed light on a
community that's often neglected and
where most people don't even know you
these communities exist anymore well
hopefully you guys have found that
spectrum is a good kind of window into
an entire community entire group of
thinking let us know what you thought in
the comments below let us know there's
anything that struck you in particular
or especially if you're part of one of
these groups we would love to hear your
opinions make sure you follow us on
Instagram as well because that's where
we're getting a lot of our prompts like
subscribe and we'll see you next time
thanks guys